we are with a pensive at least garry
kasparov right now is Gary the form just
seems like it's not quite there
well yeah but you said it's getting
better so definitely the score today was
better than the two previous days and
yeah it's blundering a piece is always a
bad idea but I have to admit that
position was not a good one so and I
still could probably kick around but I
didn't like the position and I actually
couldn't solve the opening problems and
I spend a lot of time in the opening
there yeah because it's it's quite
unpleasant so was the I think I yeah I
had to teach Schedule E 5 and play Queen
f6 that was the best chance to create
some some come to play because since you
know I miss this opportunity so he's
she's strengths these push in the center
and black can no contemplate right the
few tricks but now it's ended up with
nasty position of course instead of
playing we should play six I could play
a five that was the best move 85 so to
prevent before and then and then to play
Bishop I 660 bishops and I was on the
pressure but but also timing was
terrible so I mean I have to say
probably I was too too overwhelmed after
game one so that's a I managed to win
after so many ups and downs over well
meaning you win I won the game it just
is the it's a and it was some games it
was a big fight and and I think I've had
Betty in the opening I made quite a
serious mistake by taking d5 too early
because then you know my deal was before
to open the queenside was met by c4 so I
had to keep my pawn on c4 and they said
the moment had to confessor what what I
did and so then we play the position
that was probably roughly even so be it
was blocked but I try to I try to create
something and just managed to bring my
rook of 86 and then I lost you know a
lot of time and I had less time in the
very deepest position and then the power
of started playing at the Queen a3 so he
managed
you he thought he would be winning but I
I think I found the only defense and
then he blundered he blundered silly of
the game was was quite tough because it
was little time left and there and I was
really proud actually what I did at the
end I didn't check was computer but
actually to find an idea that the best
the best poem to pushes is the poll that
was the farthest h-bomb so this is
tonight's protected and then these
points are actually g4 and a5 they kept
black pieces a day and then h-bomb was
advancing so okay having eight seconds
you know left to make rockets it's it
was a good idea but the second game was
just you know I actually this is now
when I when I entered this room say
there was a discussion there that is
probably after efore you know the best
for black is for e 6 and then b5 so
that's the so we just have to look for
some you know different ways of fighting
because in 5d v e5 is probably
challenging and alright you know it was
blitz game I also didn't like my
position but then he managed to give ok
he gave me a chance play c4 and he
thought overlooked now I took a revenge
for yesterday's game to make Castle you
know it's why the black is much better
but I think the game was far from over
at the end so I think he was devastated
by by missing you know who'd be one but
I don't think it was easy it's easy with
black write it look like still a fight
it's interesting
you made this mention I saw you do it
yesterday as well the the day is over
the opening is over you're likely not
going to see this position again and yet
you are all discussing still what is the
best opening line in this particular
setup it's C I think someone is looking
for some sort of patterns you know
because we're still learning obviously
each position is different but there's
still some patterns for instance in air
that's today it became clear that you
know if whitener goes was efore so you
should try to actually look for the way
of playing d5 so that's just opening
your bishop so attacking the center not
to play instantly now in the center but
just going around so we dig and it's
it will take time for players just to
get along because it's there's so many
unusual patterns that we never seen
before and it's and yeah in each
position you have to be very careful not
to follow the same path and just to make
a mistake but I think it's it's that's
that's that's why all the players they
are discussing because you never know so
maybe tomorrow in similar positions you
just you you'll find out the familiar
pattern so the voyage of discovery
really each and every time you've what I
think it's discovery it's this and again
that I think we're just you know making
theory or even making history because
we're just in an opening sort of and you
not open chapter or it's just basically
a new book on the game of chess and
that's why I think we're all players
were excited final question your
thoughts about the match you need to run
up a big score tomorrow it's better than
yesterday but I said that you know I
haven't managed to actually come up with
the with the right concept was black
because I it's just position was and I I
totally miss played it but again I I'm
happy that I could recover after a
terrible miss sharp in game one was
blitz that I played nicely and just got
completely winning game game and just
she had more time and then just blew it
up it's it's such a pity sir last night
95 checkers it's just the age was
winning on the spot actually was really
going was out knight on f6 which is
against is amazing I just sorted I could
play 95 King distri and then I do the
same but with Knight you know it's I
will make him comfortable well we look
forward to tomorrow and it seems like
you're getting your strength together
definitely give you a good fight
tomorrow okay thank you
thank you